hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to the mortuary
assistant i need to get into that
basement i don't think i'm gonna do a
completionist where i get every single
ending but i need to get into that
basement i have to get the key
whatever the key is or wherever the key
is
i need to get it and then i need to get
in to the
basement grandma you were uh
you were a little spooky last time so
maybe grandma you could leave me alone
oh were those always openable
oh oh i'm up i'm up i'm up
oh
i don't have my clipboard
yeah all right whatever
i don't think there's anything new that
appears in the apartment if there is i
don't see it and therefore it doesn't
exist if i don't see it it doesn't exist
ignore that
hey boss sorry about what happened last
time boy that's embarrassing
boy i'd hate to talk about that
so that card's not there anymore i don't
know if it's going to give me different
cutscenes i mean i don't know how many
different cutscenes there are
but if it do
scribble
i think that's a meaning like level one
in the bottom left
i don't exactly know what happens
if you let that get all the way up but
that's really just experiencing a whole
bunch of different things and i think
that's just based on time
so long as i'm relatively quick i won't
experience that because i won't have
time to be possessed
welp
time to get to work
oh god why was that on delay
who do we got today no one sam burton
that sounds familiar jake kohler
and jesse pineapple
sure what do i do with this ashes
there's something about this like you
can get a bag of ashes if you use the
cremation bag
and then you have a bag of ashes and you
have a matchbox i still don't know what
they're for they must be something
secret that you can use at a certain
point in like probably in one of those
cut scenes a lot of them are drug based
so if you have a box of matches i
imagine it is something you can light
like a joint or
some kind of a drug you guys can tell
how many drugs i do because i know
how
fire is used among them are you smiling
you smiling again you sam i feel like
i've already uh treated you before sam
let's take a look at you
yeah
something's weird about your eye there
nothing's weird about your head i
suppose except for this mole
nope looking for obvious ones first aha
hello
i forgot that this was a horror game for
a moment hey no visitors grandma i'm
sorry i'll visit you later all right
there we go
strange
these don't seem like they're enough to
actually kill anybody
there they are
sam burden age 50
mole on the right shoulder
hemangioma on the left arm what is a
hemangiona
[Music]
i don't know what a hemangioni
oh that's new
hi
hello
hi what is this
what
okay
what was that supposed to be
what kind of diabolical device was that
supposed to be i don't know whatever
that was weird okay so there's still
plenty of new spooks to be had
we love that
we love the spooks uh
all right let's get to work all right
let's take a look at you
i'm so glad they don't do anything when
you're doing this it sure would be
spooky if something were to happen at
this moment
[Music]
there we go yep there we go
just normal job
just my normal job
just a completely normal job
that i do for money
and nothing else
definitely not
banishing demons
tubing oh right i forgot about the whole
letter thing
i should probably do that because i
experienced some paranormal [__]
happening
oh boy here we go
that was quick
ah umbrelli
umbrella
look at these
ah this game just makes me very
unsettled
i don't know why i've been through this
before it's the idea that there's stuff
that i haven't
experienced yet
it's fine
and i don't like how coincidental this
is when i say something and it does
something it's unpleasant
oh not again
how could there be another one already
oh doom slayer
gray
schwa bam
i also i'm pretty sure you can get these
with three
no problem
you know besides the weird not quite
iron maiden in the other room this is
going pretty smoothly
no concerns here about anything weird
[Music]
there we go
okay
there we go all right clean out the
machine
really this guy hasn't moved at all
i don't know if there's just been
something really subtle that i haven't
noticed but i haven't seen anything so
i'm guessing you're just a dead body
great sam we love that let me tell you
let me tell you we love that when i say
we love that trust me
we really do
i'm sorry
i didn't think we had a customer
uh it's the simple things it's the
simple things it's the simple things in
life
that's what makes it all worth it i
don't think you're the demon
i'm just gonna go ahead and say it i
all right who's next
jake kohler
you got it jake
wham
all right jake let's go
hey was your twin brother in here the
other day
that would make sense
okay let's take a look at you
uh
hello
hello hello rebecca
rebecca
okay
shouldn't i have said hello back
wouldn't that have been the appropriate
response did i know that voice was it my
voice
i don't know
you smiling god they're all smiling
they're just so happy
keratolysis on the right shoulder
blemishes on the left mild abrasions
left arm mild blemishes right arm
what
left leg contusion i'm sorry what was
that
what
oh express with me okay
i'm sorry what
did i see something or was i
that's nothing
definitely nothing
okay they're definitely okay hi
yep okay
no visitors
where does he get the baleful reagent
what is in the baleful reagent i really
want to know what's in the bail for
reagent
what
what was that what what oh hi are you
just slamming doors on me this is really
minor
this is like minor league stuff really
not impressed
if you're gonna do something too big
seen it all before so
you're not gonna impress me
there we go oh not again hi hello
welcome to the mortuary hello
i need to report a missing person
uh sorry
her name is rebecca
i understand that i need you to check
them
all right
i'll keep an eye out thank you
okay
all right then
okay we're still doing okay oddly enough
very oddly enough just a lot of phone
calls
nothing strange about that
it's strange
i'm going down apparently to the
basement
oh my god my phone keeps trying to scan
my face that's what the flashing is
she has a drug problem
does she
does she have a drug problem
huh
hi it's me
oh my god
coming right back
[Music]
what
hello
i'll just go back to work after that i'm
just go i just go back to work that's
fine i just get right back to work oh
shake that off
can't let that get me down you know
these bodies ain't gonna embalm
themselves all right again a very boring
uh corpse here
very boring really a do-nothing kind of
body
you know what i mean
kind of lazy if you think whoa
skadoosh oh
it's here somewhere
there we go
where are we i'll be out with you
where are we
where do you go it sounded like it was
over here and it kind of was when i
moved this way but there's nothing here
outside
could it be outside
back of the door no
all right whatever i gotta get this body
in
okay sorry
hey
oh my god
i'll be right with you god you're so
impatient
okay so i don't know what's with the
third symbol oh there it is
ah
it's a microscope okay microscope got it
i think well this is weird
ah okay
microscope yep get in there all right
microscope it is all right
thank you for your patience uh
uh thank you for using this mortuary i
still haven't gotten any closer to
actually getting
the goddamn key do you know where the
key is
you know where the key is do you have
any idea where the key might be never uh
you ever seen a key can i ask you some
questions uh okay what was it a
microscope
like um yeah the microscope okay so what
has all these plus a microscope what was
it umbrella doom slayer microscope not
part of the house of immolation
maybe part of the invidious
uh nope umbrella doom slayer microscope
aha that's a possible candidate i think
that might be it it's the house of
invidious and it's
ozell doom slayer pie boobs microscope
umbrella
that's it
okay so i have the mark
just gotta make sure i do this right
okay how you doing how you feeling i
forget your name but it's okay
that uh something no
all right
yes something on your
uh
hey
you get back in there
i can't use that here yeah you get back
in there
and three there we go
okay
there we go
they're all being real quiet tonight
i'm gonna put this back i forgot i can't
carry anything else
there's gotta be something else with
this code but i haven't been getting
anything that's gonna tell me the
answers i'm definitely missing something
i gotta take some time
while this is doing this to
really see
what the deal is it's not giving me
anything that i need so i might already
have everything that i do need what is
the matchbox for
what is the bag of ashes for
oh what the frick
what the frick
what is that what is that
what did i just do
oh what the hell what
huh
what's with that
[Music]
oh my god uh
interesting well now i have the answer
of that but that doesn't help me get to
the basement something to do with you it
has something to do with you
ah
oh no no
what are you doing
it's your grandma
hi grandma
hello again
all right you got it grandma i'm coming
don't you miss me
is it a knife oh
good
i thought maybe you could
slit your wrist for me maybe you could
do it for
me what's wrong rebecca
[Music]
don't be afraid of your treasure
oh
all right well grandma uh i'm thinking
that maybe you should um whoa i think
that maybe you should go away because
i've already got this uh this written in
i am ready for it i mean i feel like
that is a clear sign
it seems like the clearest sign you
could possibly have
that looks like a demonic posession
and therefore this would be the right
body however that is not my objective i
need to get into the basement i've been
just playing around hoping that it would
get me another cut scene but
unfortunately it looks like it might not
so what i need to do assignee is stop
for a moment and i need to look for the
basement
i need to do this might as well do the
last one of these anyway there's
something else here
there has to be
otherwise
why do any of it
oh god oh how did i not notice you
how did i not notice you it was a seven
digit code that's what's throwing me off
about it because there was a clue
yesterday that said something about it
should the number shall be six
i wrote it down because it was 1970 and
then the birthday of
the founder which is what is his name
steven
shelby six but it's
no
i thought it was seven didn't i try that
i did 1970 and 44 because he was born
1944.
i thought it was seven okay anyway i
have the hatch key is that the basement
key the basement hatch the hatch to the
basement
is this the basement key
whoa i thought i saw a
floating body in the sky
is this the key
oh my god oh
i'm in
oh [__]
um wow i'm in uh i didn't expect it to
be that easy uh
okay what is this
dear mr salah it was a pleasure working
with you but i'm sorry to say that i
simply can't afford to travel back out
to you i have more questions about the
athenian translations but i was also
hoping you could send over the documents
you had shared on quarter lending
honestly any documents you could create
copies of and send would be extremely
helpful the package accompanying this
letter contains some of the clay
carvings i have made in an attempt to
create the symbols you shared i have
also designed a holder for them my hope
is to combine the markings and hold her
to comprise a demonic identifier that
will also call the entity to it and bind
it there if correct the silver capsule
in the center of the holder contains the
ash of burned co-frees and is lined with
demonic calling runes based on our
conversations i believe this can react
with fresh blood from the possessed i
wanted to request that you give the
contents of this package a look and let
me know if it seems like a viable method
to bind an entity with privacy also
being extremely important to me i want
to request you please send everything
back including this letter all my best
raymond well that explains how this
letter got back here which was confusing
mr delver it is a great shame i will not
be seeing you but i appreciate you
sharing this with me as it does seem to
provide a reaction and what you have
made does make sense it's a very clever
way to identify a specific entity
however i am curious as to the reason
for the body identification aspect as
you would need the blood of the
possessed inside of the vessel which i
assume would already be the case in
tennessee would be obvious so i don't
really see the value of identifying the
vessel however the demonic
identification and binding aspect of
this is fantastic thank you for sharing
me your work it's a great help to mine
as you have requested i have returned
everything with this shipment with great
respect akil
all right well that's nice okay well
that explains what he was working on
just some simple carving and boom you
got your demons how's my sketching doing
ah not great
i'm not doing so good
ah may 29 18 4 uh 1984. i'm not sure why
but i've decided to write this down i
don't keep journals but it may be the
only way i can deal with what's happened
to get my thoughts out i thought this
was over but it's happened to david i
remember so vividly what it looks like i
don't have any plan here so i just
wanted to write i keep thinking about
david i feel horrible what he became was
terrifying i remember everything but i
haven't seen it in a living person
before i knew in my gut what was
happening but i couldn't believe it it's
almost been two good decades whoa really
when the body came in david almost
instantly began to become irritable we
both knew something strange was
happening but it directly affected him
he felt sick and went home for the day
only to return that evening saying that
he felt he had to come back and wanted
to work at that point i couldn't ignore
it i tried to tell him he was in danger
that this was all real he insisted on
working became irrational again and
asked to work alone i again told him
what to look for but he dismissed me i
went and bought a camcorder and told him
to at least record anything unusual i
wanted to be able to show him once he
was in a moment of clarity so that maybe
he would allow me to help him but it all
happened so fast and was over i don't
know what else to do i feel helpless i'm
so sorry james andrea now won't stop i
don't know what to do obviously not
everyone is susceptible i've learned
that much it makes me want to never hire
anyone again but i can't lose the
mortuary either even if i did close it
would still happen to me eventually i'm
back to writing here again it's been so
long i thought it was over but i guess
i've just been lucky i'm scared i was
hoping this would never happen again but
i have a feeling this is only gonna
happen more poor angela this is a
horrible existence i almost fell victim
before it it's only a matter of time now
until it chooses me i don't want to be
alone but i think there's no escaping
what has happened i'll miss you always
maria but it was the right thing to
leave you to keep you safe i know you
would never understand i took this
journal away and forgot about it trying
to move on i found it again today and i
guess i've been in a horrible place for
a while now i can't live with all this
guilt i feel so alone i feel so angry at
the life that's been taken from me i
stopped my life to take care of her and
she brought this in i can't blame her
that's not fair it's not her fault i
have to find a way to stop this myself
i've just been sitting here huddled in
fear hoping this won't happen again that
it won't happen to me i don't have much
money but i need to start researching
this in a real way i need to take
control okay so you just been letting
people die oh
that's a new one where can i play that
oh i see
this is raymond delver
i
i know this will sound crazy
but i believe i am being possessed
if i am to disappear
know that it was not of my own free will
and that i am a danger to anyone i may
encounter
i should be killed on site
this sounds
sounds terrible
but the woman locked in the basement
must also be killed
what do you mean
for anyone that may encounter this
if you are experiencing possession
the blood of the possessed will react to
the name of the demon present
injecting the blood of the possessed
into a deceased body with demonic
tendency will act as a reagent for
revealing possession
and form the foundation for binding the
demon to the
i'm sorry for what i've had to do
know that it was only ever done to stop
it all
what do you mean what do you mean the
woman interrupted what do you what do
you mean the woman trapped in the
basement asked to also be killed what do
you mean by that what do you mean killed
mert who's in here
okay
okay that's fine good good good great
good i actually am really happy about
that i don't know where a key would be
and honestly i don't care i'm going i'm
i'm leaving
i'm leaving i'm leaving i'm leaving i
don't know what that was all about i
know that the demon is right there on
the table there i don't know what else
to do about that what do you mean
the woman has to be killed that doesn't
make any sense
i don't know about any of that
i don't know about any of that and i
don't care about any of that i don't
want any of that and i don't need any of
that give me this taking this slapping
it on
you
why don't you uh oh i need to do that
nevermind put it back put it back
put it back put it back put it back
i gotta do the tank cleaner i'm just
gonna
oh
what
it's ver what was it quiet
it got really quiet
oh
that's new
[Music]
oh
what was that that i just saw
oh we're here again
oh good
get tubing by bed get needle from
bathroom find lighter get spoon from
coffee table fight full baggy on kids
okay
tubing
[Music]
yeah
needle from bathroom
oh
got it
find lighter
lighter got it
spoon from coffee table
uh-huh
[Music]
full baggie
oh
no
oh no
hi
okay
[Music]
that's probably not good i should
probably get this symbol on and get
going i'm gonna say i don't think i have
much time left i think i gotta slap this
thing on and get you in there i don't
know if that like is a guarantee though
i actually really don't know they have
all been very silent so i'm just
assuming that you're the demon because
you have the mark on your stomach
don't
you laugh at me i don't want oh no
okay let's get out of here i'm gonna
burn you
oh no i'm not
hold on
and he slammed me back in i forgot about
the mark
oh god oh no it's happening
oh no it's happening wait wait stop stop
stop
put this on
god damn it put this on it's you're not
gonna do this again we're at the very
last step i forget to put the thing in
there we go
that's what i thought
put that on there yep that's good
yep yep yep
[Music]
i'm thinking
yeah it might though
oh i'm sure yep pretty sure
oh god
and goodbye
speed run
i don't know
was i supposed to do something else in
the basement i have no idea
good
morning nice not to be the one down
there for a change
raymond
i suppose a first name basis i think i
got it right
seemed like it anyway is it over
i'm so glad i'm here oh no i know it's
disorienting
you'll get used to it oh no did i pick
the wrong one i think i'm fine
are you sure oh no did i pick the wrong
one it had the writing on the thing it
was speaking to
me just been waiting oh come on
how are you gonna tell me that that was
the wrong one
when it had the writing on the stomach
it was speaking to me
rebecca's not here you [__] idiot
have what's the basement
how did i pick the robot
they all were the same they didn't do a
goddamn thing
what
shift the three i only
what do you mean
i know one of the achievements is the
basement ending what is
are you kidding me i didn't get the
basement ending did i just get lucky on
the first one none of those bodies were
moving at all i did something with the
ash i thought that because i did that
then that meant that it was going to be
the one how did i burn the wrong body it
was talking to me it had some paranormal
[__] about it that's dumb how do you
how do oh god did i not get
the thing all right this episode is not
over until i get the basement ending
because god damn it i deserve it so i'm
gonna go and get it and hold your horses
right there because i'm gonna whatever
it is i'm gonna get it hold your goddamn
horses let's just start over again
cause i gotta get this goddamn basement
ending
all right i'm speedrunning right to the
basement to give me the most time
i'm not gonna worry about anything i
know the code it should be the same i
just punch it in i'm good go right
there we go
it's just that simple
who'da thought i don't even need to go
see the bodies
i do find it interesting that nothing
scary seems to happen outside of the
mortuary like everything is contained
into the building i have yet to see
something occur
while i'm walking outside i say that
with confidence but i know for a fact
that that's not necessarily
how it's going to be
so this is closed
is there a set of keys that goes down
here
the only other key in here that i know
of is in this drawer up top here
but i can't pick them up
i don't know if it's like one of the
things where another key will be
revealed to me if i keep going so i
guess i just keep doing it as normal
and this time i at least hope to find
the right thing
which isn't a guarantee but whatever you
know what let me just go ahead and get
the ash i don't think i can do that more
than once because i don't have enough
matches i think it said it only had one
left but not that it worked anyway let's
just get to work
these bodies ain't gonna morgify
themselves
[Music]
so
maybe that's just an indication of what
it is period
so
let's say for example i need to get the
code
hey okay that's different
um
i need to get the code uh don't mind me
don't mind me don't mind me don't mind
me uh excuse me excuse me excuse me i
don't know why the code changes every
time 1650. okay you stay there you stay
there
[Music]
so this narrows it down to a certain
because these are different symbols i've
only i've only ever seen this because
i've only done it twice but if it's in
videos
then it's got to be one of these
and because these are pretty much
exclusive
certain symbols of these one is in three
but this one is in two and that's only
in one
so it could help narrow it down i might
be able to get it early and this
certainly seems to be uh something
happening over here
pretty early on i'm just going to ignore
you
if i ignore you and just keep working
does anything happen
not bothering with that
what if i just close the door
ah damn it all right well you're gonna
be a pain in the ass why you gotta be a
pain in the ass all right fine whatever
oh okay
uh what do you need uh some money
oh uh there you go
how about that
you want the embalming report
i don't have what you need
oh boy oh boy
oh
huh
you uh feeling any different there pal
whoa
is that did that
that symbol burn front to back
no
was it only on that side
that's very strange wait what what did i
see then what did i see
what's going on there
some weird's happening there
that looks like the symbol but it's on
the back
why would it be on the back could just
be like a texture
or you could be the demon
awfully suspicious
oh
shoot
[Music]
um
someone with a giant nose sideways
sideways nose sideways knows that
that is only these two so it's either
shadat or kavos
interesting
so sideways knows interesting
any changes
you guys twitching at all i think that's
what it's like supposed to be right if
you do pay attention to these guys the
corpses some of them do subtle little
things that was that's what the video
said so if you pay attention it might
give you a clue as to what's going on
i heard that
where was that
oh hello
doom slayer okay i don't think that
narrows it down i think that's actually
in both of these doom slayer yeah it's
in both of them it's a doomslayer either
top or bottom maybe there's some like
education i can do in terms of the house
of invidious like the certain house that
they are maybe that is helping me
understand what they do like how they
hide themselves
okay additional markings oh interesting
haven't noticed a peep out of these
these guys
not a peep
not a movement not a twitch
well that's a smile oh that's a smile
all right
you definitely weren't smiling before i
would have noticed that even that
tiniest little bit of movement there
what's going on with you you having a
good time there bill you being sneaky
you think you're being sneaky i know
that smile i know that's a smile
that's a big old grin
see you're not smiling you're definitely
not smiling
nope i don't think you're the one i
wonder if i could just jump straight to
it
i mean it doesn't really matter the
whole actual mortician work it's about
finding the demon right
isn't that what this is all about
[Music]
[Applause]
oh my god hey what's up pal
that is suspicious i'm not gonna lie
that
that's pretty suspicious
oh my god oh my god i just heard a noise
from in this room let's uh let's keep
that smile looking bright there pal
there we go still smiling
you actually manifested something in
relation to the body
and i'm thinking that's important
hello
how are you
good to see you there you okay
all right
oh well
probably fine
oh that's not good
oh boy
hi
oh that's not good
oh that's not good where am i what am i
what am i oh
yeah i think this might be the body
hello
hi
oh good
oh
good
okay well that's fine i think i listened
to that this seems like the basement is
is is there someone in a wood box under
the basement what's with the blood
oh
is that the crying i heard
boy what are you doing here i don't i
don't know
what am i what do you do what it where
where do you do the what
hm
cornucopia
oh
oh why is he
closed oh here we go
where is it
where is it at
give it to me
scuba oh god where is it
oh where is it
is it in the basement
there's no way is it in the basement
no
it's not
is it no where is it
oh
what how
what
must be in there
ah
that's a
l dot
l dot got it
l dot magnifying glass oh this is
another nose actually that's a nose
magnifying glass okay that's it right
so what happens if i just go burn this
i don't think i even need to finish this
do i i think you're the demon
i really do
i'm gonna go ahead and put this on your
chest so i don't forget this time
pretty sure you're the demon
okay there you go
are you sure this is the right one
absolutely
one hundo percent
oh well i don't need to worry about that
prepping you for your demise
oh boy hmm
oh boy what's happening
oh
well that kind of confirms it you know
that uh that that that
yep okay into the fire here we go you
ready to go get burned away
you okay
well this is go
do you uh should i really
okay
well you ain't gonna trick me um
because i know for a fact
that
hey
you know you're trying to stop me but uh
you ain't gonna happen to do it do you
did whoa hey bud okay that's weird
that's really weird uh
into the flames
into the fire i'm not even gonna wait
here we go three two one egg burn
hi what are you doing out there you're
supposed to be in there
that's weird
that's bizarre
i ain't gonna question that
i'm pretty sure that's the right one
i know you oh did i get it i got an
achievement that one was pretty obvious
you know
oh he's gone
i'm not gonna lie that one was pretty
obvious after it was started really
subtle with the smile
but uh yeah
all right let's see if i
get the special basement ending
i don't think there's any mistaking that
one if that's not the demon that i'm not
going to be very happy
what about the basement
good
is it over isn't this the same wait what
about the basement
oh what
how do i get the do i got to open the
door to the but i don't know how i don't
have the key
oh
hang on one second
collect the key open the door in the
basement finish her but i but i couldn't
get that key what do you mean collect
the key in the bottom i can't collect it
what am i
in the bottom wait in the bottom
belonging wait bottom
what
[Music]
oh that
changes things
interesting
trying to get a good look at them
no smiles
normal feet
normal arms
normal expression okay
good to know but now i can get into the
basement i didn't know that was there
who'd have thought
man that was suddenly
that was subtly hidden too okay so what
is in
here
are you out
there hello
oh i knew you'd find me
i'm all alone and i'm scared
please
will you help me
[Music]
ah now i know how you get the baleful
reagent it's the blood of someone who is
possessed
ah
fascinating
i see and i think now i have to finish
out my shift and i'm willing to bet i
have to guess the correct possessed body
so i've never had
higher stakes in this moment
all right
any changes
already nothing
not a thing
oh hi
i saw you
all right let's do this
i need my bag of ash so i can find out
which house it is right away that is
very handy
still house of invictus huh
interesting incident insidiousness
whatever it
was oop
we got our first one oh
where are we at
where was that
not on the doors
oh there it is doomslayer all right that
doesn't give a lot of answers
is either this one or ozell or mossette
[Music]
that's fine there we go
oh that's not fine uh
why are you appearing again
do i need to give you something
i don't have anything to give you
that seems to be something where i need
to give
something the hands are out
as if to receive something
therefore
all right it would make sense
to give something whoa hello
ah
aha
magnifying glass
all right oh
that's easy okay magnifying glass up top
all right
i have the demon weird sonic and beaker
all right uh
i have it well let me just let me
experiment with something what happens
if i just you
you know wham
uh are you gonna say something
nah
fine
how we doing gang
doing good
looks the same
feet are normal
no new marks
feet are normal hands are normal
this is going to be one that's very
subtle again it seems like this house
moves very subtly
oh
that's not good
ah
what
what was that
oh
wait a minute whoa
what was that wait wait whoa
where
what
what all right it's weirder that the
door didn't open
it's weirder that the door didn't open i
don't know why but it's weirder so far
nothing weird about this one the body
itself hasn't done anything area people
okay all right let's get you back
hmm
i gotta get this right if i mess this up
after getting this
not gonna want to do this again
okay leave you out who next
you
oh
was that the basement
occupant i don't know how you got
that person into the basement coffin
very strange hello were you talking you
don't want to talk anymore okay that's
great can i get in here
i need a nap you know it is quite a lot
to just trust that everything's going to
be fine with your assistant and that
they're not going to be possessed so i'm
i'm not actually surprised that when
you know i die
oh
hate that
or i come back possessed and i killed me
oh you should be a little more cautious
than that if i just had to say why did
that save
you just got a saving symbol why did it
do a saving symbol hello how are you
dead i know
not seeing a lot of movement
really nothing going on what happens if
i were to let's say just
plop this on your uh chest there
what do you think of that
are you sure this is the right one
interesting no that's no guarantee
but uh
just gonna leave that as it is for now
while i do my paperwork
stop
go away
oh [__]
don't do that that's uh that however
that is something happening while
this is going on but that's a different
demon that's a different demon that does
that so it's not necessarily the same
let me check see if there's any changes
over here
nothing
man there's just nothing happening are
your feet ordinarily gray have your feet
always been gray that seems weird that
seems very weird
i feel like i would have noticed that
where was i tank cleaner
yeah probably tank cleaner
oh
back here again i remember
ooh
okay yeah
there hasn't been you know even though
there's been events tied to this body
there really hasn't been that much going
on nothing twitching
there's the graying legs but that might
just be like i don't know mud or
something i feel like
i feel like maybe i have seen that
before i don't know it's hard to say
say that again you talking to me all
right you know what
okay
oh boy
what was all that
that was weird
okay
i see
all right so it is you
good to know um i'm gonna just slam you
right in here then uh thank you for
revealing yourself to me that is awfully
convenient um nothing else to change
over here right not a single peep yep
okay i'm confident that seems like it's
obvious
thank you
have a good day
if that's not it i'm very upset you've
come a long way
it's nice not to be the one oh no oh no
are you kidding me
mr dover
i think you can just call me raymond at
this point
oh maybe he's just passed out and wake
up on the floor maybe not
it takes a lot out of you
i've never simply walked out of here
after
you get used to it
i'll be sure to clean the floors better
raymond is different will this ever end
this is different
i honestly don't know
i've been doing this a long time rebecca
i've traveled all over learning
everything i can
i've never found anything that could put
a stop to it
so no
i don't think it does
so
we're just like this forever
it was hard for me to
but this is a life we get
we have to face our worst selves
constantly
but the better we know ourselves
the stronger we are
why don't you head home
get some rest
who knows what's coming tonight
are you kidding me
you're not going to mention anything
about the basement
[Music]
all right i have to end this because
i've been recording this one episode way
too long at this point it's been about
two hours i got some spooky stuff i
think what probably happened is it like
needed to get to this ending
or there was some other step that i
didn't do i did burn the right body i
banished more demons but there's also
something more like with the hanging
ghost the palms out clearly there's
something else here that i'm missing so
not only will i get the basement and get
an answer to that out of mr devin's or
whatever his name was
i'll get an answer to whatever else is
here because there's two more endings
here that i have not gotten then this
game is fun so i'm gonna keep playing it
thank you everybody so much for watching
and as always i will see you
in the next video
bye-bye
[Music]
you